this podcast has been a form of comfort
and even therapy for me
i don't know if people sense that at all
and so i called zach on here so that we
could reflect a little bit on the big
picture arc
of where we started back in
let's call it beginning of 2018. when do
you put as the start
zach of uh our adventure together
running for president so i got i took a
number of months i actually tried to
like find the exact dates on
this um because i've been um
i've been writing a book on the kind of
this journey which is fun
actually everyone zach has been writing
a book and i have read
i have read excerpts from it and it's
awesome uh evelyn has read both
uh parts of his book and the parts of my
book that's coming out later this year
and everyone prefers zach's book i just
want everyone to know that
that's uh mine's more about like the
journey right and like the roller
coaster yours is more about like solving
problems and
um where we go and things like that
um so you can see why evelyn prefers
accidents so zach tell us about
uh tell us about uh the book the journey
and when when did you say the journey
began
so um that's actually the number one
question i get andrew's like how'd you
beat
andrew so i knew andrew from
so i knew andrew from my daisy ubs i was
helping rich people give money to
charity
and they loved andrew they loved venture
for america andrew was
a rock star in the social
entrepreneurship space now that is a
tiny space to play in
um but we would have him and come to our
like client events all the time
i'd seen him speak on panels and cre and
was always very great um
fantastic at them um and you could i
guess humor would come through that kind
of thing
andrew yang panel star
for sure i'll never actually this is
funny yes this is so funny do you
remember this okay i want to set this up
so this is not in the book but um
you did a panel at we used to do these
um basically billionaire kids events
like if you're super wealthy and you
bring your kids like how do you inherit
like 100 million
types of events and we'd always do
something like a philanthropy day
and you did a panel with a guy named
adam braun
um and if you wanted to pick like draw
like the perfect like white boy stud
it's probably adam braun
he's like quite stunningly good-looking
like went to educated rich like started
this non-profit
and he tells this he tells this story of
this organization at the time called
pencils of promise
and he tells his story about how he goes
to africa and he asks a kid like what do
you want most in the world
um and he said a pencil and it's like
this heartbreaking story and he's
telling this in the context of saying
like my whole life my parents had told
me like bronzer special
bronzer special like and he knew it in
his heart when it happened until
and there's not like a dry eye in the
room like everybody's like oh my god
adam
and then it's like and then the
moderator's like okay andrew your turn
and he's just like
andrew you go yeah you know my parents
told me the exact opposite actually
they're like yay you're not special
they're like go to law school do
something traditional like work for a
law firm like you're boring and he's
like even my non-profit like
it's like oh it's teach for america from
entrepreneurs let's call it venture for
america like nothing about this was
special in my ad and the room just
lost it um that was my first like debate
experience theoretically of andrew yang
without knowing it that was probably
2016.
on my hat 2015. and i have to say
coming to those events was always a
treat because um the environments were
always super nice and the food was good
and like you know
like sometimes there was like you know
that there there was a celebrity or
entertainment oh yeah one of the kids
at the table somewhere they were fun um
now so so zach and i knew each other
through that for uh a while so it's true
when someone says like how did you meet
andrew like you would have to backtrack
to
maybe whatever were you in 2015. i met
you and so i asked you to be
my roommate actually worked for you
worked for venture america joe guy
um and he was like you have to go joe
guys a great guy
joe guy mr knife mr guy um
but he was like you got to meet andrew
you guys are two forces of nature to
actually tell direct words
um and i asked andrew to be on my board
of my non-profit and andrew's like i
love this idea
sure how can i help i'll be on your
board great um there's a classic andrew
like yeah if
i can if my name can be helpful which it
was to get more people more legitimacy
anyway so i had heard long story short i
heard andrew's
your shtick like hundreds of times and i
went to this dinner and
andrew it was
it was april i think of 2017
is like the timing of there wow it's
somewhere in like er
like late night somewhere that mid-2017
yeah yeah that'd be right before the
summer i thought it was summer it's not
and um i went to this like jeffersonian
roundtable dinner i used to go to all
the time it was like very pretentious
like 15 people meant to be on a topic
and this was on the future of
work and i was curious about this topic
and i go
and i got the list of the roster and i'm
like oh there's gonna be all these cool
people here i'm excited
and i go to this like restaurant i think
he's in the west village or somewhere
downtown
like private room and who parachutes in
andrew yang parachute team
and i remember being pissed i mean like
damn it i've heard your spiel
a hundred thousand times where you're
like hey we're like we got all the smart
minds in the world doing six things in
six places we need to get them
out of like the new york and san
francisco's in the world and get them to
detroit and cleveland it's in a great
it's a great pitch but i was hoping to
learn something
and yang comes in and just drops this
bomb like takes over the room and drops
what i eventually called like the
automation bomb which was like a working
version of the war on normal people like
why donald trump got elected here all
the jobs the united states
half of them are going away and then in
the middle
in this room after he's got the whole
room like captivated
and he's like and i'm running for
president united states
and it was like you could hear a pin
drop it was like
president president of the country like
of america
uh and uh how he got connected
afterwards i was like well andrew i was
looking at i just paid off of student
loans i was like looking to
leave ubs um and i was like hey andrew
i'll help and you're like great you can
manage a campaign something like that
well because i knew i because i knew you
were very very strong
you know you were a builder you were a
doer i mentally thought to myself
uh like you know i need to make sure
that zach is into this
because he elevates our chances of
impact and success
uh dramatically immeasurably
and so this let's call this like spring
2017
uh i mentally was like super pumped
about it and then i
resolved then to try and uh update you
periodically and keep you updated so the
main thing i was working on at that
point
was a manuscript for the book uh and so
i would just send you pages
oh yeah okay so i got coffee and vote
uh this is your book we got coffee this
is one of the rare times you get to go
behind you and pull a book
and i get coffee with andrew probably
two weeks later and he sits across and
he slides me this book
raising the floor by andy stern he's
like first of all read that
and then this is like this is what sold
me on universal basic income and the
second thing i asked i actually whole
bunch of questions i don't remember this
i was like
jeremy skelton's in the closet you're
like no i'm boring i go like it was
right around like this is the height of
me too it was like just starting i was
like you're knocking please i'm not
doing this you're getting me well
what's funny too is like you know exact
exact new people i'd worked with i think
we could
check and be like hey does this andrew
have any of that actually they were like
no
i did a lot of research that and then i
was like well what's your plan
you know i could help with money i'll
always hustle the fundraiser like what's
the plan of money and the path here and
you
you pulled up the new york times um this
was so precious
stuck with me you pulled up the new york
times i think it was new york time i
didn't watch the post but i think it was
new york times infographic
on the republican primary and how much
money they raised and how they
performed and you said yeah yeah and you
said um
you're like what do you think the
democratic primary field is going to
look like and i'm not giving this that
much thought i was like i guess probably
pretty crowded and i can't really think
of a front runner
yeah like it's gonna look like the
republicans there's gonna be a ton of
people running
and so i just need a lane to get my
message out and be considered serious
and then he's like now everybody thinks
you gotta raise billions of dollars in
politics because like the reality is
republicans do that because they can get
super pac money
but i've looked at what these clowns i
think was i don't know the exact word
but some of these guys on the republican
side had raised
and it was like it was like huckabee
uh carly fiorina a couple named ben
carson there were a couple names
that were christie that were yeah
christy that were big names that it only
raised like
one to three million dollars if i recall
and you're like i can raise that
um and like we can do like that is a
feasible number to be a serious
contender
and i remember i don't know if i said
this number to you but i i think i said
this to myself i was like i can raise at
least 29.
um and and 20 million would have put me
in like
fairly serious contender category we
ended up raising 40.
uh but i i in my mind's i don't know if
i ever said this to you out loud zach
but i was like
you know like i had an internal goal i
was like we can raise 20 mil
for like such a ridiculous goal
presidential
a presidential camp i mean it turns out
i was a little bit cocky and unrealistic
because
then when we got into it like you know
it was actually very difficult to raise
the first year was rough yeah like
you're like raise four mil much less
like 20 mil though we did eventually get
to 40 with a bunch of escape velocity
and thank you everyone listening to this
i have a feeling you probably
contributed to that 40 million so thank
you thank you thank you uh super super
grateful but yeah i showed you that
infographic i was like look
this democratic primary is going to be a
zoo they're going to be over a dozen
candidates like we just need to raise
uh you know x million dollars to be able
to fund an operation
and compete yup i'll know i'll i'll fast
forward a little bit but you in the
when we finally got in office so this is
probably may i think either april
may of 2018
yeah um you we were like straw we were
stre the first year was really hard to
raise money
and you were there and you were they
said like you know zach i got to say
zach i never i never told you this but
this this was like a big thing for me
and you could actually get into this
maybe
so so the timeline is you and i do this
thing in spring 2017
i'm like sending you stuff being like
hey man it's great it's great it's great
i filed the paperwork for the uh
presidential campaign in november 2017
which obviously no one notices or cares
no one cares i got it all the time oh no
not yet sorry but i got
i got the article in the times february
2018.
so there were there was a four-month
period or so when i was uh building and
uh
you know like uh coming up with policies
and
like graphics and like all of uh this
kind of stuff
uh email addresses and then during this
time
i i did never not tell you this i was
like there is a
you know i thought in my mind's eye i
was like there's like a 20
to 20 to 30 percent chance that zach uh
realizes that joining me in this is is
very very foolhardy
because so so there was like a part of
me that was like oh [ __ ] like if zach
realizes this like
that that's going to be very difficult
for me because i can't
kind of uh you know have zach pencilled
it as the like
you know operator campaign manager um
and so
every day between when like you know we
we had launched and before you
left ubs uh full-fledged and enjoying
the team i i had that this like
no [ __ ] i really gotta you know like
make sure that zach actually
sees the path and the light i appreciate
that and so what was your last day
of getting paid by ubs because this was
like the period when i was like
is that really going to leave his uh his
sweet uh
banking job to join our madcap
presidential campaign so when was that
date
so i didn't end up leaving
my first date uh day
on the campaign i think was march 2018.
either march 1 or like middle march um i
have a date in the book
and what's the name of your book the
book is y'all called long shot
right now uh there's a subtitle i can't
remember and when's it coming when's it
coming out we'll do another
pod when yeah we'll do it we'll dive in
the book we'll give you the full-on
author treatment yeah but everyone now
like their their appetite is being
wedded they're like i'm totally it's
it's it's meant to be funny it's meant
to be all the stuff
it's like the book i think the end gang
wants to read about this i hope that's
my that's my goal um
there's a lot of stories like andrew it
is that's why someone else is
my my book is my book is not really the
book the yang gang wants to read but uh
but yours is and yeah that's what
everyone said
i think it's funny from political lens
too we'll see um but
uh so i left ubs
yeah i was like look i was like is this
real or is it not what sold me guys i
read the manuscript of the book
and i jumped out of my bed in one of the
chapters i remember calling my brother
and i was like i gotta work for him i
don't know i don't know why it just
feels the right thing it feels like call
to do it
and then it was like it was one of the
things like if i didn't do i'd regret it
the rest
of my life um and so
like my first day let's say it's like
march 1st 2018. i never
uh we were at andrew's mom's apartment
before we
got our first office and there was what
three other people plus you
uh one guy muhan was living there um but
i remember showing up in like
a suit and i didn't wear a tie because i
thought that'd be too fun but i wore
like a suit and i was like oh wall
street ready
and like i got in there like 8 30 i was
like man you know like maybe 8 o'clock i
don't remember what time it was but it
was early it was like you know
um like a morning and muhan wasn't even
out of bed yet and there was no one in
this office it was just
no one in the apartment and i was like
oh this is going to be different man
the apartment was full of boxes because
that's where all the boxes from his book
uh were being stored amazon boxes i was
like man
okay this is uh this is not
or not in kansas anymore
[Music]
you